لن يفعلوا هذا إذا
اعتقدوا أن لديهم خيار وطن لهم هو
إثيوبيا ، لكن الآن على بعد 700
ميل من السير ولم يتم دفع بلادنا ،
يخبرنا أحد الشباب بذلك ،
فأنا مصاب باليمن
اليمن من  اليمن يقول إنه يمكنه الوصول إلى
السعودية للعمل لإرسال الأموال إلى
والدته ، ومن الصعب فهم
مستوى الفقر الذي قد يدفع شخصًا ما
نحو منطقة حرب خاصة عندما توجد
أهوال تلك الحرب على
نفس امتداد
الخط الساحلي الجيبوتي مونيكا.
قُتلت زوجته وابنته في قذيفة هاون
قبل ثمانية أشهر ، ويخبرنا كيف أمضى
سبع ساعات في قارب صيد للفرار
إلى مخيم اللاجئين هذا فقط للوصول
واكتشاف مقتل ابنه في القتال
مع نجيب وعائلته
فقط.  وصل على مدى السنوات الخمس الماضية
حوالي 25 من الأقارب والجيران
وقتلت قريته في نفس المنطقة ،
سألنا نعم إجابتك بدلاً من
مدد الاستسقاء ، اعتبر إيسيتا المسيح
أنه يتذكر رؤية ميجر
يحاول المئات من الإثيوبيين العبور إلى اليمن
على الجانب الآخر من الطريق في مركز العبور هذا ،
حيث ينتظر المئات من الإثيوبيين
إعادتهم إلى وطنهم في الوطن ،
والذين أرادوا القيام برحلة إلى
اليمن ، ويقول مور البالغ من العمر ثلاثة عشر عامًا إن
الشرطة أوقفته قبل أن يتمكن من
الوصول  يقول على متن القارب إنه لم يكن يعلم أن
هناك حربًا في اليمن
ولا الأطفال الآخرون هنا لم يعرفوا
عن جثث المهاجرين التي
جرفتها الأمواج على شواطئ اليمن ولا
يعرفون شيئًا عن القنابل ، الرصاص أو العقول أو
يبدو أن قذائف الهاون حتى البالغين لا
يفهمون تمامًا ما ينتظرهم ،
وحتى لو فعلوا ذلك ، لا يبدو أنه
مهم في المحطة الأخيرة قبل اليمن
، يتجمعون تحت الأشجار للظل
والحماية من الرياح
وانتظار المهربين الذين كانوا  فقط أقول أنك
تعلم أنه ربما توجد حرب في اليمن ، ربما
لا توجد حرب ، وقلت لا
توجد حرب في اليمن وقالوا جيدًا ، ثم
علينا أن نترك الأمر لله ، فهذا
بعد كل شيء طريق هجرة تاريخي
وإلى  هكتار العديد من هؤلاء الرجال  وصل خمسة من الأقارب الذين
نجحوا في ذلك قبل الحرب عند الغسق
، حيث وصل المهربون لقطيع
المهاجرين مثل الماشية في أعلى التل وفي
اتجاه البحر ، أخبرنا أحدهم أنه
يرسل مجموعات يصل حجمها إلى 200 عبر إلى
اليمن في يوم طلبنا اتباعه ولكن
يحذرنا بعيدًا هذا هو آخر ما
نراه منهم أروى ديمون سانتا كتاب جيبوتي